what you are about to see is a review
written and recorded by my wife she has
never seen or read Hunter hunter before
and it is a completely blind impression
of episode 1 as a result she may
mispronounce you know a few names here
and there but hey that's fine now if you
like the sort of stuff please do let us
know with a like or comment down below
but for now enjoy the ramblings of my
wife hello and welcome to new world
review your source for everything
everything anime you are probably
expecting Liam's voice today you get me
his wife Chantal also known by me as
Grand Line waifu trying something new
I'm admittedly someone who doesn't watch
a great deal of anime or not as much as
I would like to be watching as someone
repeatedly hearing you need to watch
hunter hunter from their husband who
runs a channel discussing it no less I
thought it was probably time to say
goodbye for now to re watches of Kenshin
close the window with the last episode
of attack on titan say arigato and
farewell for now two food wars and
prepare myself for hunting squared bad
at maths and since there may be other
people out there who haven't seen it it
made sense at the time to share my
impressions of the first episode so if
you haven't seen it either or if you
have and are interested to hear how a
casual anime watcher sees the show this
first episode review may give you a bit
of an idea about what you're getting
yourself into and why there's so much
hype around a series that seems on the
surface to sit in the formula of a lot
of other series a literal Google search
tells me the series was directed by the
same director as my beloved rurouni
kenshin Kazuhiro for hoshi and that
among many other things explains why I
enjoyed watching the first episode of
the show episode 1 then it's very
focused on the idea of get out please
quick get out while maintaining the
appeal of the town to those who stay
it's it's gone immediately apart as a
bit of a curiosity and endearing
curiosity at that I do need to say that
the first half of the episode carried my
understanding of the second half if I
only half paid attention to the first
half I would have been entirely lost by
the second half and that's probably by
design the beginning serves to pick you
up and carry you on a journey the
writing is tight clear and very direct
in its storytelling and a joy to watch
everything I know about hunters the way
others think of them the way they hold
themselves the fact that gods father is
or was one and the
way he's discussed that's where I get my
information from the environment around
the main characters as well as those
characters discussing others
I value learning fact second hand if we
need to be told about someone and to go
back to the director I really appreciate
that he seems to insist that every
character big or small has a really
clear understanding of how they feel
toward a character they talk about it's
a credit to the entire team that they
give us that subliminal understanding
something I truly loved about Kenshin
was its commitment to complex emotions
the opening of Hunter hunter wasn't
complicated it resembled Pokemon and
seven deadly sins in so many ways that I
wondered whether I was going to be
watching another boy wanting to be the
very best and honestly I'm not as here
for that simplicity as I was when I was
seven however it very quickly left that
trope behind as I saw the relationship
Gaughan has with meto now I haven't
looked up anything beyond the creatives
involved in the anime to remain as
unbiased as possible and what stuck out
to me was the fact that as of episode 1
I actually don't know whom Ito is his
mum it seems odd that he calls her Mito
and that she uses his dad's name with
him a foster carer a friend her dad's
partner gone doesn't seem to be her
brother and he seems to take on wisdom
from her in a way that my sister
certainly didn't listen to my wisdom
when we were that age
despite watching and sort of analyzing
what I was seeing at first knowing I'd
be writing this review I felt myself
drawn to Mito in a way I hadn't expected
and I was glad she came up again whether
we see her again I have no idea but I
very much hope so because she set the
emotional tone for the episode in a way
that drew me in possibly more than any
other element the reasons for gone to
want to go and train to be a Pokemon
master I mean hunter and her reasons for
wanting him to stay were absolutely
evident in that opening half episode a
lot of information is very handily
communicated in that first 10 minutes
and as I reflect I feel I understand the
world a great deal more than I thought I
would after one episode but I'll come
back to that in fact of what are the
main cast for this first episode are
there reasons for leaving home seeking
to be hunters are intricately flawed as
someone with a deep interest in
psychology at drew me an annoyingly
quickly forgotten to be leaving to
understand his own abandonment makes me
wonder how long he's been trying to
catch that one fish yet the lightness
with which that opening scene is handled
makes me wonder whether gone is a
multi-faceted fool or trying to hide his
brokenness behind a smile
I also eagerly await the moment he gets
to meet his father and what kind of
reception he would get from that solemn
serious Cora pikas reason for leaving
home is simply vengeance in his case I'm
most interested to see whether he'll
compromise his desire for revenge when
he's face to face with those that killed
his people and by how much it's a very
clear set up and they didn't make us
wait to have that backstory information
though they teased that they might for
all of 90 seconds the game now is to see
whether that information comes into play
very quickly while it's still in our
minds or if we'll be left to forget it
and remember some information later I'm
sure there'll be a test lay or do dear
lay audio a comic relief lanky tall
older obsessed with respect and
recognition which he seems to think
he'll get with money by the end of the
episode we do sense there's hope for him
yet though the resolving exchange
between Korra pika and Li Oreo was
probably the whole lowest moment of the
episode for me it felt very much like we
needed to wrap things up because time
and so we wrapped it up I very much hope
the reason they were angry and why they
gave in so quickly after the storm is
something we can return to as the series
continues because while I understand
their motivations and why they were
angry I'm not certain I feel it's
justifiable to change your entire life
outlook after catching a boy flying out
to sea
then again I have never caught a boy
flying out to sea while I was in a jewel
situation I understand that it needed
resolving and having watched the
post-credits scene I can see that it's
not all hunky-dory but as someone who
may have stopped at the end of a single
episode I struggled being good people at
heart is a great concept but it's very
difficult to show in a shortened time
frame which I guess is exactly what
happened here
ah before I forget back to the world it
was entirely forgotten which is probably
why I forgot it - there was a lovely
picture of a seaside town a big fish
with crustacean legs the lord of the
lake told us that we weren't on earth
but somewhere similar somewhere with
hunter exams what is a hunter exam
no one knows especially not me all I
know is that it's worse than seasickness
a lot of things are worse than
seasickness maybe it's a clue to how
much sea travel there is in this world
can't be a hunter if you get seasick
after all really though despite being
reminded that the reason Gunn's leaving
home is to take the hunter exam to find
out why his dad just had to abandon him
the idea of the exam wasn't particularly
important to me
it got lost in the idea of travel and
became as important to the story in this
first episode anyway as the storm it was
an abstract way to get gone out of town
which is technically wrong because the
episode ended with the captain changing
his mind about them attempting the exam
which I'll admit wasn't hugely
believable for me either that kind of
really quick change was insane bordering
on absurd since the only one he really
spoke to was gone but let's brush that
under the rug of episode oneness we
can't fit everything in maybe that's why
it became less important to me as a plot
point ah music I haven't talked about
music and sound what an oversight from a
sometimes musician our first experience
of the show is a poppy poppy number
which combined with the cutesy features
of little GaN and friends my alternative
title for this show by the way
gone and friends all gone with friends
going through a preteen title sequence
of bright colors and cheesy grins gave
the impression of exactly the energy I
thought the hunter hunter episode would
have throughout in fact looking back at
it it's entirely possible that the
Pokemon vibe I got is heavily influenced
by the style of the music and the bright
colors involved in the opening title
I'll jump to the end title briefly
because I'm going to be heavily biased
and say I struggle with voice modulation
zin music it's a personal dislike of
mine and so I'm not actually going to
discuss the music in it other than to
say that the actual tone of the music
only somewhat fits the tone of the
episode we just saw with that in mind I
think it's important to highlight just
how much I love the practice of changing
theme music part way through anime
seasons what that will hopefully do in
this case and seems to have worked for
every other anime I've watched where
this happens is change the tone of the
series when things become fingers
crossed more serious further down the
line the music throughout the episode
seems very gone focused by that I mean
it's mostly up-tempo and playful which I
think adds to the youth of the episode
the composer seemed to be very much
pushing for the lightheartedness of the
environment what I find particularly
interesting though is that in moments of
depth the music fell away leaving the
focus on the voices more importantly
every scene with strong emotion depended
on the voice actor to carry it without
any sound effects to help bold design
choice if the actors went up to the task
luckily as I said they carried scenes
marvelously well so will I watch more
the answer is probably
I enjoy anime I enjoy the style of
animation unlike some I love held images
way to communicate heightened emotions
it's used a good effect here so I'm
hoping that continues and I'm hoping
these heightened emotional states and
the character focus conflicts that come
up continue to grow and develop
I think I'll continue to watch until I
feel I'm not getting that engagement or
until I'm just bored at a glance there
are 148 episodes to watch which is nice
I don't need to worry about running out
of episodes for around 3,000 minutes the
themes of the anime are already touching
on some of what I expect and hope to be
the core elements of the show family
friendship emotions tenacity and trust I
hope I continue to enjoy it and that is
all of my thoughts or most of my
thoughts the thoughts I could remember
on hunter hunter episode 1 if you
enjoyed this video and the content this
channel produces in general then please
do consider donating to the New World
review patreon because the support of
all of you amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
if patreon isn't quite your style then
please do leave this video a like share
or subscribe because it also helps
support this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
then please do head over to the discord
server where a wide array of shenanigan
ori takes place on a daily basis and
finally please do comment with your
thoughts on departure and Friends
episode 1 of Hunter hunter this has been
the new world review and I'll see you
next time
[Music]